you know it's like we're living in the
in the first days of mass
self-organization you know Clay Shirky
likes to say this is as big a change as
the invention of the printing press was
500 years ago we now have ridiculously
easy tools for organizing ourselves and
so the political impact is huge the the
the presidential election just is like a
huge training ground so there are
thousands and thousands of people who
have just gone through an experience of
effectively discovering how good they
can be as organizers right they've
learned how to survey their own local
political landscape and figure out how
to deliver the votes that were needed
for the larger cause in this case of
electic Obama many of these people
aren't going to they're not going back
to what they were before this you know
the Obama campaign surveyed their
supporters after the election they got
about half a million actually filled out
a detailed survey and ten percent 50,000
people said they're interested in
running for office which means a whole
new wave of energy entering the
political process at every level and
whenever that happens you're bound to
have a change in it as well in what the
incumbents do and as these people get
elected and then rise and you know start
running for higher office it has a
larger societal effects oh I think you
know you might call this the Obamas
coattails and he is just the beginning
of that much bigger wave that's going to
spread through American society assuming
you know that we don't have a political
disaster I mean assuming he he lives up
to the promises that he's made
you